est-ce que tu as déjà fait des partouzes
il dit non elle publie fait où
alors dites-moi Sami justement vous avez
un bon avocat quand même quand vous le
savez mais non parce que c'est le même
que Chirac bien sûr c'est un mode avocat
parce que là la dernière fois
franchement en juin dernier vous étiez
pas au mieux vous aviez pris 8 mois de
prison avec sursis 5000 € d'amende et 3
ans d'annulation de permis bon ça a
l'air beaucoup comme ça et par rapport à
ce que vous avez fait c'est pas énorme
ce qu'il a fait oh il a il a tout pourri
pratiquement tué trois polonais porte de
Bagnolet mais alors si je comprends pas
avec toi ce que j'arrive pas je viens je
viens faire la promo du DVD reconnaître
des bandes annonces ou tu me fais mon
curriculum vitae judiciaire écoute ce
que je te propose Samy ce que je te
propose
une interview moralité d'accord allez
vas-y bon interview moralité
Sami est-ce que vous êtes déjà fouillé
dans le sac de votre mère
non voilà
c'est pas moi c'est immoral de fouiller
dans le truc de sa mère
est-ce que vous avez déjà copié sur
votre voisin à l'école
Sami est-ce que vous avez déjà triché un
examen oui
mais moi j'essaie
est-ce que tu as déjà menti un casting
ah oui
je crois que même le principe
est-ce que tu as déjà abusé de ta
célébrité pour draguer une gonzesse
jamais ah jamais non j'avais les filles
en ont abusé mais moi j'en ai jamais
abusé
[Applaudissements]
Sami est-ce que tu as déjà insulté un
plombier
je vais essayer
Sami tu as déjà eu recours à la mort
tarifait l'amour tarifait en français
dans le texte ça veut dire quoi les
les alors j'ai grandi là-bas
et voilà Sami est-ce que des recours à
des substances illicite jamais
moi je trouve pas dans le jardin tout ça
moi je vois des arts quand je fume donc
c'est pas la peine
en fait en gros
ça peut être coupé dans le truc on sait
jamais
ça peut arriver tu as déjà pratiqué des
orgies partout non jamais
est-ce que tu as déjà fait des partoutes
il dit non et le public fait où
passer votre temps à parthuser
ne m'oblige pas à sortir la fiche que
j'ai pas sorti tout à l'heure bien
je vois vraiment que vous êtes un être
extrêmement respectable et je suis
content vous voyez qu'on ne fait pas que
votre procès quand vous venez dans cette
émission on essaie de vous réhabiliter
chaque fois tu m'as oublié une petite
commande
jamais fait est-ce que vous avez déjà
insulté une hôtesse de l'air sur le vol
Paris Canada Paris Toronto non
est-ce que vous avez déjà aidé une
vieille dame à traverser la rue oui pas
pour lui piquer son sac non non pour
l'aider à travers en plus elle voulait
pas aller de l'autre côté
on va garder les deux au montage bien
alors Samira c'est beaucoup plus grave
est-ce que vous avez déjà regardé TF1 de
samedi soir
oui comme tout le monde les matchs de
football il y a pas de match de foot
il est à côté quand même il est
corporate est-ce que vous avez déjà
acheté une dose d'Hérault à 100 balles
jamais j'ai été relaxé d'ailleurs pour
pour cette dose d'Hérault c'est
oui c'est mon ami spinner qui m'a
défendu et qui m'a obtenu le relax c'est
un super avocat je vais te dire autant
prendre un bon surtout quand ils sont
sur ta gueule
je sais pas ce que j'ai écrit là il vaut
mieux ah oui
trois polonais aussi c'est
il méritait pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'ils
avaient fait ils m'ont fait des queues
de poisson ils m'ont embouti ma voiture
j'avais ma copine qui pleurait à côté de
moi c'est il mérite une gifle ou deux de
toute façon j'ai payé j'ai payé trois
polonais je les ai défoncé
et du coup bah après tu as eu le
résultat parce que tu l'as annoncé tout
à l'heure ça s'est bien terminé ça c'est
bien bien terminé donc qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire que tu as pas trop de moralité
mais que tu as un bon avocat on peut
dire ça mais j'ai de la moralité quand
même un petit peu
tu aimes ta mère je l'adore c'est
l'essentiel et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu